le bonheur des enfants continuent
d'animer les journées et les soirées des
petits et des grands
le 20 décembre n'a pas dérogé à la règle
puisque des milliers de personnes ont
déambulé dans les allées du jardin de
l'état pour profiter pleinement de
toutes les activités
ici c'est une découverte particulière
sur les modèles des maîtres verriers qui
est proposé vitrail un hommage à
l'artisan guy lefebvre qui a fait une
exposition au musée vilain lors des
journées du patrimoine
donc le principe c'est de on a quatre
modèles qui ont choisi trois couleurs
fabriquer son objet c'est ce que propose
également la bibliothèque départementale
qui dispose pas moins de trois stands
choix d'édition avec un stand totalement
dédié aux ateliers fabriqué plus de noël
on a fabriqué des cartons à fabriquer
il fleure comme celle ci en tout cas
cette année
travailler autour de l'enfant et de la
nature crée la thématique du mougnan
descente sans cette année autre
découverte pour les visiteurs du co2 teq
historique de l'océan indien qui à
travers différents supports sensibilise
aux problématiques de l'environnement
particulier autour de jeux sur des
tablettes des sur des ordinateurs sur
l'environnement sur la végétation de la
réunion par exemple avant l'arrivée de
l'homme et de nosy également des espaces
naturels de l'océan indien
les différentes propositions qui font le
bonheur des enfants puisque ces derniers
quel que soit leur âge trouve de quoi
pour s'amuser en compagnie de parents
qui pour le coup participent également
on est parti voir les animaux on a
regardé le cinéma 5 t
tu as beau manège en famille c'est un
peu tard
avec les parents et on pourra profiter
c'était bien on est parti faire plein de
choses on a vu les des spectacles qui
avait le cinéma scinder les animaux la
cabane y avait eu on peut découvrir les
choses
les animaux on peut fermer des sols
effet l'atelier fleur de sel qu'on a mis
dans un chocolat et apprenez à déguster
et tvo après on est parti à la ferme au
respect de cet appel et c'était y avait
plein d'animaux y avait des activités
après je suis parti faire de de la
peinture et je suis parti faire des
quizz sur les ordinateurs et les
tableaux on a fait un superbe décor
annuel les fêtes on a mis au monde et
gyrophares intérieur que cannelle et
puis on fait une petite décoration c'est
super bien qu'ils ont fait l'atelier
avec l' orange avec le chocolat aussi
s'en sont mis plein les la bouche des
piles et après
une leçon l'élastique il y avait la
photo avec le père noël bien sûr jeu
très sympa et c'est gratuit
alors il faut en profiter une journée
particulière puisque la liberté a été
fêtée en cette journée du 20 décembre
mais le bonheur des enfants voulu aussi
commémorer l'abolition de l'esclavagé
jessica percée a proposé un concert à
l'image de la réunion avec une musique
métissée d'influencés diverses
la petite fille qui chantait le ligne le
yang a bien grandi et a mis le feu à la
scène de bonheur des enfants